Um,
this is,
this is basically going to be an entire master's course in about an hour.
So you've saved a lot of money.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I hope this is vaguely interesting.
I hope that you're interested in kind of the story of us because this is what it
is.
This is a story of humans in the last 15,000 years,
in the last 15,000 years,
we've made some changes.
Um,
so yeah,
this is the book.
It's about a third gossipy footnote.
So just to give you an idea,
uh,
which is kind of what this talk will be also,
everything is killing you.
Everything.
I think many of us has,
you know,
sort of suspected this was true,
but not known it,
not been told it by scientists.
So there you go.
Yes,
you're right.
Everything is killing you.
And the question is really,
I think a lot of us look at sort of modern urban lives and sit there and go,
why,
what,
what have we done?
Um,
what happened once we were roaming the savannas with perfect abs,
perfect teeth?
Has anyone seen sort of stock photos for Paleo Diet magazines?
We looked amazing
what happened.
Um,
I'm not sure that we can really say the Bacon Flavor cupcakes or the harbinger
of the apocalypse,
but it might not be far off.
So there's,
there's a,
I think a real sense that people have,
which is that somewhere between technology and bacon flavored cupcakes,
everything is killing us and it turns out that this is something we can actually
do science about.
This is what I do,
um,
is trying to explain how we got here,
how are we got hunched over our phones,
sort of worried about the size of the Dentin or office chair.
And it turns out,
um,
it's kind of a long story.
Um,
and the way I'm going to tell it is through my field of experience.
I am a professional digger up of dead people.
I am a bio archeologists.
This is a real job that you can actually have.
Um,
and uh,
and so,
uh,
this book is actually mostly about kind of the evidence from our actual
skeletons from our actual bodies.
That sort of speaks to how we have ended up as a nearly 60% urban species.
So by 2030,
the idea is that human beings will be 60% urban.
We are already majority urban dwelling species.
This is pretty much the biggest change that we have made sense,
you know,
some serious decisions about trees some time ago.
Um,
and I'm going to try and tell this story mostly coherently.
So we're going to have to start at the beginning and the beginning,
um,
is probably best address.
This is not an archeological dig.
This is archeologist digging out a car.
Um,
I'm going to start in Jordan they see is a series of very prominent academics
who study this sort of crucial change between the measle ethic and the
Neolithic.
The muser lytic is our hunter gatherer days.
The Neil ethic is the fancy stuff.
This is when we come up with a major changes which are settling down farming,
domesticating animals.
Uh,
but first you have to get there and it turns out Jordan is a wonderful place,
but the roads don't always work.
Um,
so we have really some quite prominent archeologist,
um,
directing some less prominent archeologists as to how to dig a jeep out of a
wadi and me taking photos because I'm helpful like that.
So let's talk real estate.
One of the first major changes that our species made was just settling down.
We have been free range for a very long time,
200,000 years.
Uh,
well it depends on how far back into our history you want to go.
But settling down is a pretty shocking change.
Uh,
yeah.
And you can see here the reconstruction,
this is,
I'm further up that not road and this is what he finance and Jordan and someone
has made a reconstruction of what one of these very early year round dwellings
would have looked like.
They did not realize that if you put a fire in something without a chimney,
it is not very good reconstruction.
So they did nearly kill quite a few archeologists.
This would later rectified.
So,
um,
experimental archeology can be very exciting as Ken archaeology in general.
So moving,
trying to move on.
This is also what happens if you take prominent archeologist up a very steep
road in Jordan.
And then it turns out that uh,
some four by fours not actually meant for four by forging through Wattis and the
battery will fall out and then you will have to bed when teenagers,
the gentleman without shoes in the picture here,
um,
who come and tell a room full of professors how to fix a Toyota.
Um,
it is,
it is a remarkable experience being an archeologist.
Sometimes again,
note my level of helpfulness.
I am in the back taking pictures.
But this is so,
so this,
this radical decision to stop wandering around actually has real physical
effects and in sort of theory of if you don't use it,
you lose it.
This applies to your skeleton.
If you don't put constant pressure through use on the bones of your body,
it's um,
you know what the bone doesn't feel much like building itself up.
If you're not building up muscle and things,
you can actually lose bone density.
And what we see by going around CT scanning,
x-raying,
measuring very,
very particularly is there is a change particularly in our lower legs when we go
from wandering around to sitting still.
So this little diagram,
um,
because I wanted to make sure you felt like you really got a lecture.
So there are boring diagrams for you.
Um,
this is kind of going through time period.
The very top there,
the CCR,
that's the bone density of a cross country runner.
So if you see that line,
that's the top,
that's actually that bone density is of your Shin,
which is of course you know your Tibia as the bone,
you bark on coffee tables.
It's a painful,
but,
um,
but in a cross country runner that Tibi is really important.
You actually build up more bone if you're an ultra marathon runner or um,
you know,
professional running,
you need that Tibia.
So you have a much larger,
but by the time we get to the Neolithic,
you can see that first little t shape bar there.
That's a lower level.
And then also for comparison,
we've got some,
I'm Adam,
an islanders who are not living in totally settled life.
Um,
we've got,
uh,
sedentary controls and then we've got field hockey players.
I'm not sure why they included them,
but apparently not,
not the strongest hippies in Rome.
So we've already revolutionized our bodies just by selling down.
We've got skinnier legs.
Well done us.
I'm now going to move slightly further over and um,
just because I guess,
well this is Google so we're going to go to Auntie Kythera and this,
is anyone ever heard of anything involving computers?
Nantucket throw.
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you for nodding.
So,
um,
the end and to kick through is mostly well known for a shipwreck that went down
off side of it.
Um,
lots of things sink there.
Uh,
for the end kits re mechanism,
which is occasionally brought out.
Um,
and newspaper editors like to call it the world's first computer.
It is not a,
it's cool.
It has gears a computer.
It is not,
but,
um,
the reason I am telling you about an antiquey throw,
cause I had to spend a lot of time there and so we're going to spend a lot of
time there.
Now.
It's a beautiful island.
But the one thing about this wonderful,
amazing island,
other than the fact that the boat is way bigger than the harbor,
which means that the boat does not always make it into the harbor,
which kind of sucks if you have 25 undergraduates and there's no more food,
um,
hey,
get restless.
Um,
it was actually kind of awesome.
I will say that,
um,
because this high,
they don't think it's about 40 people living on it.
Um,
it's,
it was completely abandoned,
cleared off by the Nazis and the Second World War,
um,
it only is for the people living on it.
They're all elderly,
none of them farm or do anything any more than involves making food to the food
comes on the boat.
So if you take the only car,
luckily there's only a mile of roads and no one really misses the car.
Um,
but if you take a car to the big island to buy food and then you come back,
uh,
and you can see the shore and you have the car full of food and you can see your
undergrads and they're,
they're kind of on the headlands waiting for the food and then the boat just
doesn't land in,
it turns around and goes to create and you have to have an enforced holiday in
Crete.
Um,
when you come back there is anger.
moving on.
It's a very harsh landscape.
It's quite a prickly landscape.
Um,
it's actually sort of a more or less a barren rock and Molossia is quite
difficult to live on.
Um,
this was the situation we were reduced to trying to watch the World Cup.
What you can't see is the coke cans and the clothes hangers wired into a fence
in an attempt to boost the antenna almost worked.
This
is actually what I want to talk about and goats will be a major theme.
Look out for goats where this a drinking game,
goats would definitely be a shot,
but goats are the next step.
So the goats on anti Kythera are basically a walking larder.
They are or once were domesticated now that there's only 40 people to control
them,
they kind of roam free.
They hide in abandoned villages.
They peer at two from Ridge lines.
They're super threatening actually.
Um,
but they were at one point moved to that island probably by one,
potentially by Cretins or someone else and they were sort of held their and
manage their in order to feed humans.
These are domesticated animals and domesticated animals are a huge step for
humans.
This is a very exciting,
you know,
meals on hooves.
Yes.
We no longer have to go chasing these things.
We can bring them into the house,
have them on hand,
you know,
you're walking larder no longer is walking quite so far away or so fast.
However,
is it a good idea to live in the same house as a goat?
Possibly not.
One of the things about the domestication of animals is that it puts us in very
close contact with animals and also puts us in very close contact with secondary
products.
These are and everything you get out of an animal that isn't me.
So milk for leather,
all of these things,
milk in particular and the Mediterranean specifically has been a longterm
problem because goats have something called brucellosis and brucellosis.
We'll do this to your spine in case anyone's wondering.
Your spine should not be riddled with holes that is not normal,
it should not look like that.
And this was actually a huge problem,
only finally solved by pasteurization,
which got rid of the brucellosis bacteria.
But um,
we see evidence of brucellosis entering the human skeletal record with the sort
of domestication of animals.
So great job finding a new source of food,
but stair is still a potential for it to either kill you or at least make life
dramatically uncomfortable.
Going back to dramatically uncomfortable.
We will go back to central trick.
A lot of my work is in central Turkey and the sort of um,
large agrarian planes,
central Anatolia.
And this is a Shiklah Hayek,
which I think is pretty much the coolest guy ever.
So you will all be forced to agree.
And this is a reconstruction of a Neolithic village.
So finally,
combining all of these sort of them Neolithic things that we've done with
settling down domesticating animals and um,
domesticating something else,
which is of course what the Paleo Diet would have you believe.
He's killing you right now.
Um,
this is wheat.
Well that's Mu Gay and knew gay is tending to her experimental crop of Neolithic
wheat.
So not are not content with building an experimental village.
We've now got more gay doing experimental week.
Um,
and I have to admit the thing you learned about Neolithic farming,
is it boring because I watch me,
okay,
do this for like hours.
And then I was like,
no,
I really have to go now.
Um,
because what I'm interested in is not just,
you know,
the sort of invention of Wheaton,
how people did it,
but what it did to us,
and this is where we come to my actual real sort of scientific specialty,
which is in fact teeth,
dental,
tissue analysis.
Um,
but for your sake,
we are not going to go deep into that.
But teeth are probably one of the most obvious places to look for changes that
happened with a neolithic.
The way we eat changes in what I would like to call the pot noodle phenomenon.
We move from a very sort of quite a big variety of foods to something that might
have quite a lot of carbs in it and carbs that don't require a lot of
processing,
don't require a lot of chomping with the reduction of sort of,
you don't use it,
you lose it sort of phenomenon.
You get a slow reduction probably in the size of your job.
How many of you were,
um,
have wisdom teeth yet?
Yet increasingly people are born without wisdom teeth.
If you don't have room in your diet as possible for the wisdom teeth,
just to not form that is one of the major evolutionary changes that is happening
to our species right now.
We are losing a tooth.
There are people born without wisdom teeth and presumably without attending sort
of pain and dental bills.
So teeth are actually incredibly interesting of the story and I could go on like
a lot longer.
But for your sake,
I won't.
Um,
some other things that agriculture has allegedly done to us.
And this one is fairly,
or like a,
you know,
there's,
there's a smoking gun here.
Uh,
there are some things wrong with his dentition besides obviously the fact that
it is not in a person anymore.
Um,
there are giant gaping holes in the teeth.
This is caused by bacteria.
These are carries.
If you were allowed to just eat bacon flavored cupcakes,
this is pretty many never brushed your teeth.
This is pretty much what would happen to you.
So the change in our diet actually changes the bacteria in our mouth and the way
it's able to affect our teeth.
We get rotten teeth.
So we've got shrinking jars and rotting teeth so far,
the Neil ethics looking great.
Now it's looking shiny.
This is a tooth.
Take my word for it.
Um,
this is actually a sputter coated lightly sputter coat in about micron of gold
cast of a tooth.
Um,
this canine.
So your big sort of vampire teeth,
your teeth,
her fossils,
they formed when you're a kid.
Um,
there are a perfect record of everything you do.
So if you break a bone in its back together,
yeah,
we're pretty much,
we believe that chip a tooth no,
doesn't happen.
That's just expensive.
So your teeth had these wonderful fossils and they have a record of growth.
So can you just about make out the horizontal lines that are created that are
crossing that tooth.
Your tooth is like a tree.
You have tree rings,
these are actually visible on the outside of your tooth with the sort of bill
tools.
If you brush your teeth,
they're probably gone by now.
So sorry,
before you go home and go like,
oh,
I didn't grow.
Um,
I hope you brushed your teeth.
I really advocate doing that.
Um,
but this,
at those lines for what is about every week and that gives us a record of growth
from about one year to six.
So we can actually look at that and work out not only sort of your growth
pattern,
but when growth stopped,
can you see the big giant Gash that's like on the top third of the teeth.
There's a big gaping line.
Something bad happened,
something happened to that kid where resources going into growth stopped.
Common causes would be disease,
malnutrition and particularly fevers.
So those are reasons why you would have these lines on teeth.
And what we can do is survey these lines on teeth and start building up like a
population level picture of when kids are getting sick and try and look at
whether those kids are getting sick pretty much all at the same time.
Um,
which might indicate it's something to do with the way their lives go.
And what we find in the Neolithic is a story that we can probably best explained
going all the way over to Paraguay.
Um,
these are,
uh,
chain indigenous people from Paraguay and they are trying to illustrate my
point.
That's obviously why they post for this picture.
Um,
they,
uh,
in the 1970s,
the RJ who had been a hunter gatherers were forcibly settled and moved into a
totally sedentary,
totally agriculturally based life.
They are Chang generally as hunter gatherers had children about four years
apart.
Um,
if you've ever tried carrying a toddler and an infant at the same time,
you will understand why if you try doing this in a like rain forest where you
need your hands to also get food,
I mean,
you will understand that four years is cutting it fine.
Um,
in sort of in normal childbearing practice and went hunting and gathering went
out in the jungle,
you know,
the child doesn't get more than a meter away from the mom.
However,
when they moved to settled commendations,
suddenly you could have multiple children sort of around one seven,
you know,
one grandma or Auntie sitting there.
And the birth spacing decreases.
It goes to about 2.5 2.7 years on average between siblings.
So we see you can have more babies and this is kind of the story of the
Neolithic.
We have never done anything that is so good for building more humans than just
sitting down and making more babies.
Um,
and it's made a huge,
huge difference in our lives.
Said this is Chad [inaudible],
which is another one of these neolithic sites also central Anatolia about a
thousand years later.
Um,
and this is really coming into the time of villages and villages are very
exciting by the way.
There's almost no gaps between these buildings.
So those ladders you see are actually how you would move around.
You get on top of the roof and walk around on top of other people's houses.
I saw that,
act it out once.
It was hilarious.
Um,
so we kind of,
villages and villages are where we start to get new stories and they also have
an impact on us.
This rather unprepossessing picture contains some of the most sort of,
um,
well pernicious and deadly evidence for things that we later come up with on our
journey to urbanism.
Okay.
It looks like dirt.
It was dirt,
but that dirt is a series of small walls,
which has Eddie Izzard is informed us as the entire point of archeology.
Um,
but here,
does this work?
Oh,
it does?
Okay.
Um,
these are storage bins,
storage bins,
the Tupperware of the Neolithic,
not very interesting at sort of first glance and second glance and when you have
to draw it and when you have to dig it.
But when the,
in the village,
in the Neolithic village,
we see a movement from communal activity,
a egalitarian societies feasting together,
sharing resources.
You can have sort of a special person,
like a shaman or something.
And in the gala Terrian society gala Terrian just means,
you know,
everyone's equal.
While they say it means everyone's equal.
It's like Barbara still gets screwed on the whole deal.
A while,
frank,
it was like,
ah,
everyone's favorite.
Um,
but you move in the Neolithic,
you move from a relatively egalitarian society to a society where resources are
no longer held in public these storage bins or in a house.
That house is accessible by one group of people,
not by everyone.
You start to see orphans,
places where you would do cooking,
moved from outside to inside.
And you start to see a series of small walls and these walls build up
differences in access,
access to resources.
And this is kind of wrote inequality and the road to cities that pretty much
hangs over everything else we've done for the last,
let's go with about 9,000 years.
Um,
you start to get,
uh,
in temples there's a special room or special people can talk to the gods.
Uh,
and you know,
there's a special storage room where only your family can go.
This is what we're talking about in terms of access.
We can see it in the archeological record through walls and we can start to see
it three and material culture.
This is the standard of or the royal standard of or which is very exciting.
Um,
if you're me and this I think you can all see this is,
um,
this is from about,
well,
4,500 years ago,
quite old.
Um,
can you see there's one dude who's bigger than the rest of the dudes.
That is the important guy.
And this is what we're talking about.
We're talking about hierarchies.
The hierarchy is necessary to get all of those human beings to live together,
result in someone being at the top register of that standard.
Also their goods.
So the,
this sort of,
um,
this,
this inequality and access resources,
again,
we can actually start tracking and skeletons to access resources includes access
to food.
This is your skull.
It's not your go,
let's hope it's not your skill.
Um,
what is quite difficult to see.
But you can just about make out,
she sees little pinprick holes and things that are here.
This is a very small,
delicate sign that you have scurvy,
vitamin deficiencies.
If you do not have access to a wide and varied diet because you are not the dude
at the top of the chain,
you can start to see nutritional deficiencies.
And we actually start to see these at the sort of beginning of urbanism.
So there's scurvy,
everyone's favorite rickets.
Rickets is a disease of childhood.
When you don't have enough vitamin D,
uh,
your bones are sort of the mineralized and when they're growing to mineralized,
um,
just the weight of walking on them.
Bose,
the amount of shapes.
So this sort of typical bowed legs of Rick,
it's actually caused by the weight on the skeleton and these,
these bones not being really properly mineralized.
So they sort of bend slightly.
Uh,
the good news is you can mineralize those bounds,
but you can't really get them back into shape.
So we start to see evidence of vitamin deficiencies.
And of course there are other things that inequality leads to,
which is go back to standard of,
or someone is more important than you.
Someone wants what you have.
I'm pretty sure this guy at the bottom here did not choose to end up in this
position.
And this is the story of violence.
This is the story of humans being terrible humans.
I think we all are aware of the sort of,
um,
axiom that humans and aggregate suck.
Um,
I don't think that's been disproved yet,
but,
um,
we start to think about cities and we start to think about,
the kind of violence inherent in so many people living together.
Uh,
and in our defense,
chimps are way worse.
Chimps,
her terrible,
terrible people.
They're also terrible.
Chimps actually just chimps are terrible.
Um,
so actually this is actually a really big question is how violent are we?
I mean,
compared to sort of other mammals and primates and thanks.
And,
um,
how long have we been that terrible?
So this,
this is a bone well spotted.
Um,
it's from semen,
deloss voices,
which is a pit of bones,
which is in Burger House in Spain.
That is huge,
caustic region.
It's got caves everywhere full of dead people.
Very,
very old dead people are not necessarily people,
but hominins.
So people came before I said this is from a homo antecessor site and a bunch of
bodies were found in a cave
with cut marks
850,000 years ago before neanderthals,
before we even got around to sort of being properly sophisticated and having
royal standards of,
or people were terrible people.
So there is a long evolutionary history of violence and conspecific violence,
which is just fancy way of saying,
you know,
human on human.
Um,
so I mean,
are we really that bad given the chimpanzees will kill anything?
It's going to have a chance.
I'm very mean about chimpanzees.
I'm slightly scared of,
I'm sorry.
Um,
you know,
and that we have a long evolutionary history of violence.
And this is another thing that by archeologists can look at.
Um,
this is your skull.
This is your skull on violence.
That is a depressed skull fracture.
Um,
so where are you to be hit aggressively on the head with something you would end
up with a fracture in your skull?
I think the surprises now when this picture actually is interesting because this
is a healed depressed skull fracture.
If you were to find fresh,
sharp edges,
it would be something that had happened recently at,
especially if it's sort of punctured in through the brain.
Um,
person would have died.
It,
uh,
so now you're all qualified for forensics.
Um,
but this is healed.
You can see the soft edges where the bone is slowly net over.
And the story depressed skull fracture is actually really interesting.
It's one of the first things that I was interested in.
Um,
when I started this whole archeology Larc,
I grew up in California.
You may be able to tell that from the accent or not.
I've been here for some time.
Um,
but,
uh,
California is home to the Chumash Indians and they,
sort of cover an area from Malibu to sort of up through Santa Barbara.
So obviously a terrible place to do field work.
Um,
and one of the,
one of the first papers I read was about this woman,
this whose skull was found.
And the Chumash are these excellent.
They live on the coasts.
They're,
they're basically sort of,
um,
they invent money.
They sort of live in one place,
but they're not really urban people.
They're just kind of chilling with boats and stuff because it's California.
Um,
and so then there's this one lady there and they found her skull and she has
nine depressed skull fractures.
I thought that was very interesting.
Why,
you know,
what in your life happens that you,
this many depressed skull fractures,
we know that,
you know,
they can be,
signs of violence are associated with things like domestic abuse.
Before we invented cars,
basically all depressed skull fractures were pretty much violence or falling.
Um,
but falls are unlikely.
So this one I had nine.
And um,
it's uh,
find that paper explained that I'm farther north and a different grapes and
highly judgey.
Spanish friars had observed and grape if native settle an argument and what they
had done was sort of two,
two people would sort of face off and each one would have in their hand a
spatula.
It's like a sweat scraper.
It's basically stick with possibly a shell on the end.
It is,
it is actually a slightly permittable weapon.
But what they would do is they'd face each other and they'd sort of,
um,
to settle the argument,
they would each take a swing snack
and whoever drew blood one argument was settled,
everything was peaceful.
And I just,
I,
I'm,
this woman had nine such depressed skull fractures,
like wow,
way to hold true on an argument.
You know,
you obviously survived at least the first date.
Um,
but actually this is kind of belying the underlying story of violence like this,
which is that we see evidence of violence in the skeletal record,
but it's not necessarily the sort of,
um,
massive competition that sort of,
you know,
wars of conquest.
A lot of it seems to happen at times of instability.
So we see depressed skull fracture is actually less in the early,
early cities.
They are more frequent sort of prior to or when cities are collapsing,
when urban civilizations are really collapsing.
Um,
so it's possible that actually as people move together,
it becomes less important to actually bash someone over the head then to just
look like you're capable of doing it.
And this is the idea that as we sort of move into a more urban world,
in order to cooperate,
in order to get that many people to live together,
as long as you sort of,
you know,
walk softly,
carry a big stick but don't actually hit anyone with it,
um,
it's actually much more conducive to a larger group of people living together.
So this is the site that I currently work at,
which is my favorite science.
So you can see a lot of it.
Um,
this is Basher Hayek.
Uh,
currently we're not digging because it's about hour and a half drive from the
Iraq,
Syria border in Turkey.
And it's not a good scene.
Um,
these are spearheads,
these guys,
this is like a pile of spearheads.
So you might think,
okay,
dig up a grave,
tons of spearheads warrior,
right?
Then you get me,
I show up on site.
I'm like,
no,
there's are two 12 year old kids.
Sorry.
And then you have to sit back and think why,
you know,
have we got all these spirits?
And it might be that actually spearheads are more worthwhile as sort of an idea
there.
They're actually more worthwhile.
It's something that you could exchange and impress people with than his actual
weapons of war because cities need to bling.
This is a very important part of cities.
You impress your other urban elites without mad bling,
goats,
goat bling.
It exists.
It's actually very impressive in case anyone wants to know.
Um,
we killed very few people,
uh,
on this expedition.
I'd like to point out that this is basically how all of this information gets
retrieved.
Um,
both of these archeologists lived,
it was 50 degrees in our defense.
Um,
and this was all excavated highly sort of,
I'm efficient team working very hard not to constantly chain smoking in like
trench and with modern techniques that really sort of,
um,
to be fair to me,
actually the entire thing is recorded.
Photogram uh,
photograph metrically and will be built into was sort of astounding.
3D which actually looks quite cool and spins around in the sauce and their
drones.
Um,
but also there are some practical issues just with digging.
The other cool thing that is on the site,
and I don't know if you can actually make it out,
but what they are digging is a mass death pit,
which brings us to other questions of human violence,
which don't involve one person smacking the other with a spatula.
They involve more concentrated violence.
So is it true that cities are,
when we get big scale community violence,
let's ask Germany.
This is a very pleasant place in Germany,
um,
except for in the Neolithic.
It might have sucked to live there.
The towel high massacre is now relatively well known,
but until fairly recently people assumed the Neolithic,
that sort of happy village time.
Um,
it is,
it has been accused of being this sort of yogurt crocheting zenith of a
archeological theory that essentially,
you know,
in the past everyone sat around crocheting their own yogurt and that was,
a thing.
And it turns out now,
they also committed huge massacre occurs with their farming implements,
wiping out entire communities.
So the history of people killing and wiping out entire other communities.
This is actually tell home is much more recent than,
um,
there's a site near Lake Turkana,
which has certainly been suggested to be a Masker of 26 people,
um,
with Arrow heads,
with blunt force trauma.
And that's dated 10,000 years ago,
well before any villages even in that area.
So we do know actually that people are terrible people.
And one of the things that,
um,
sort of been pointed out is that actually,
you know,
modern warfare might kill less people as a percentage of the population that
exist in total.
Even despite this,
what a mass casualties and the horrific things that happened around the world
that we actually might kill less people now than we did as angry little
villagers.
Um,
and there's a paper in nature it back me up on this so you don't have to believe
me.
Um,
this more boring charts for you.
You're welcome.
Um,
that's us.
We're over there.
Um,
and that is chimps.
I am totally,
totally justified in saying chimps are terrible.
Um,
but uh,
just as a general animal,
this is a nature paper from last year.
Just as a general animal,
you have more or less violent tendencies and these are measuring conspecific
specific killings.
So you know,
species on species violence.
So the more terrestrial you are,
the more territorial you are.
Things like that,
different ways of organizing yourself.
And if we take this back into the past,
now you don't have to read that and just realize that this is an arc.
This is an art going up.
So starting at the very beginning from the Paleolithic,
which is all the way over there,
and it goes up like this.
This is Europeans coming to North America.
That is the best we ever got at killing,
wiping out huge numbers of human beings.
But we have got better our,
our levels of how many people are killed by people are actually more similar to
where they were in the Paleolithic than where they were in the medieval era.
So we don't need to jump off bridges just yet.
There's another thing about urban style conflict though that we do have to think
about.
This is what a Mongol siege looks like.
Um,
many of you will not have seen one of these in real life.
So I provided a picture.
Um,
it is not the actual siege of Kaffa,
but um,
it is there to illustrate the points.
So Catherine was an Italian trading outpost more or less on the Silk Road.
The Mongols were less interested in this being there or they just wanted it or
something and they started attacking.
Unfortunately this was in the mid 14th century and they all got very sick.
The besieging army was suddenly struck down with some sort of terrible pasture
lands and they decided that the best possible option because they were all going
to die and they hadn't managed to take half of which just start chucking the
dead bodies over the walls into Cafa.
Um,
and that's giving us our first,
well first known,
um,
example of biological warfare.
And of course what did they have in sort of,
um,
you know,
they made 14th century,
this was black death and that is actually very much a city story.
So they is an urban trading city,
this genuine and they are,
they have this little trade out post.
Their city requires trade in order to survive.
The economics of Urbanism Require Routes,
trade,
um,
all of the things that move people and goods in order to survive.
That's what an urban economy needs even in the medieval period.
And what else moves on roads,
diseases and armies.
Now for our college is actually plague is very difficult.
It's very annoying because until the advent of modern genome sequencing,
we were really bad at finding it.
There's no way to tell because played kills you quickly.
Unlike some of the other fund diseases which kill you very slowly and make
changes to your skeleton.
Plague kills you quickly.
Um,
but we can dig them up in Nice little neat rows.
This is from the royal mint side in London.
By the way.
There are huge plague pits all over London,
like everywhere,
like under Liverpool Street station,
like anyone who has to go through there,
a lot of plague.
Uh,
you're fine now.
It's not contagious.
Going back to armies,
armies carry other things.
Um,
armies are full of,
well traditionally men,
uh,
but they are also generally accompanied by other professionals.
And one of the things that,
um,
we're still baffles archeologists,
uh,
is a story that sort of begins with the siege of Naples,
like sort of begins in the new world.
Then there's some Columbus action and then nobody knows what happens.
But by the siege of Naples,
which is depicted here,
there is an army that is marching and he's marching with a new disease,
which is going to make everyone freak out.
And this is syphilis.
Syphilis is bad for you don't get syphilis.
This is actually third stage syphilis.
So syphilis,
uh,
if,
if you're interested,
um,
actually can lie dormant for quite some time.
So many people would have died of other things well before the syphilis got this
nasty,
but this is properly nasty and we actually recognize it through this
characteristic appearance,
like hardened chewing gum on the SCO called carries sicker.
Um,
so syphilis or something by rocky,
just like,
cause we can diagnose it.
It's like,
yes,
great.
I know what this is.
Next one.
Oh,
I don't know.
Um,
I feel bad for Mr. Norris,
who's actually the surgeon who collected this and not the civil lytic.
But yeah,
problem with syphilis of course,
is that they thought mercury cured it.
Hence the amusing catch phrase a night with Venus,
a lifetime with mercury awkwardly.
Mercury makes you go crazy,
but so does neurosyphilis.
So it was kind of a tossup,
which one would kill you?
Mercury poisoning or the neurosyphilis.
But I kind of think if you've got the point of being mad,
the mercury might've been just a relief at some point.
So coming into kind of the story of modern cities,
we've talked about diseases that are moving between cities and the sort of
increasingly globalized,
sort of acquisitive,
you know,
sea routes and roads.
Um,
there are other things in the city that can kill you.
One of which is working,
working can be a t o the city is an incredibly exploitative economy that eats up
people.
That is what urban economies do.
They draw in more people in for long time.
London killed way more people than it grew.
Um,
it just ate immigrants from everywhere and it brought them in and it put them to
work in places like match factories,
matches.
You should be made white phosphorous.
You should not hang out with white phosphorous.
It is not good for you.
Um,
these are two gentlemen.
If you see these little,
um,
weird sort of wooden boards that they've got,
those are matchsticks.
What they're going to do is take the match sticks and dip them in white
phosphorous so that the heads have white phosphorous.
So they are hanging out over an open vat of white phosphorous.
This is your jaw on white phosphorous.
This is a bone necrosis,
uh,
where the bone is died.
Those are so much poison,
has been taken out,
the bonus and actually rotted away.
Um,
we like to take our students to see these and tell them that it glows in the
dark.
It doesn't,
but that's all right.
But so the work can kill.
Everything,
can kill you.
Everything is killing you.
Back to my original point,
but this is actually where I get slightly more optimistic,
which is essentially
in the sort of late Victorian era,
people refuse to be killed by white phosphorous.
It was in a city,
you know,
the,
these horrible working conditions,
they're actually fixed in a city.
So we had the match girl strike,
which actually a very impressive early strike and it got such a tension.
These poor people who were being exploited,
they have these terrible working conditions and they're dying from their work
and it leads to strikes and it leads to progressive change.
It leads to 1912 the banning of white phosphorous.
So it,
it is sort of,
it's a horrible story,
but there is little room for hope and just go to the sort of very last bit
because cities obviously are continuing to killing you.
The other way they're killing you is because they are polluted.
If anyone has tried to breathe in London recently,
you may be aware of this fact.
Um,
and uh,
and actually I,
I'm not,
I'm not too sure there's room for optimism on that,
but um,
back,
back in then I said,
well,
go back to the 19th century and water supply.
The Romans had a great water supply.
The Victorians had totally forgotten about this,
that they just ignored it and made their own and it didn't work very well.
And this is a contemporary cartoon showing all of the horrific things that are
going into the Thames and then coming out in your drinking water.
And we come to this map.
This map is one of the most famous maps,
um,
for all of sort of health professionals.
This is Jon snow's map up dead people.
There was a cholera epidemic in Soho and it killed a lot of people.
Um,
and there was a big conversation about how you got cholera.
You've got cholera.
Everyone thought it was a Miasma,
which is this like sort of specter of this cloud of noxious fumes.
Sort of like,
um,
if you've heard of people in the black death,
fighting the plague with like posies with burning herbs and things.
It's the smell that gets you,
this was a really current medical theory.
John Snow was like,
no,
it's water.
Don't drink the water.
And everyone's like,
shut up,
you know,
nothing.
Jon Snow,
sorry.
Sorry,
my friend,
my friend came up with that joke and I've stolen it.
Oh.
Um,
but so Johnstone,
he sort of,
he actually gets aggressive and so he starts mapping the deaths.
So he's drawing out these little blocks or the number of dead people and
they're,
they're also surrounded in an area.
Okay,
that makes sense.
It could be just noxious air in one area,
but
weirdly,
the people in the workhouse who have their own well are fine and the brewery
workers aren't fine.
And this is because of course,
the source of contamination is a pump,
which is bringing out the cleric water.
The brewery workers are fine because they're drinking beer because why would you
drink lemon water?
That is a terrible idea.
And because of this you get major structural change.
And this kind of my point with cities just to stop everyone from like jumping
off a bridge,
um,
we do fix the problems of cities in cities.
Uh,
Jon snow went through the waterboard.
There are,
you know,
this is where the solutions to the problems that cities come up with come from
their urban problems,
but it doesn't mean that we're totally doomed.
Um,
there are choices,
there are choices that we can make probably whether we want to go like full
dystopia.
Um,
I really enjoyed mad max,
don't want to live in it.
Um,
or you know,
whether we want to let 'em Patrick Stewart lead us into sort of the future.
I'd say I'm way more on the star Trek Front.
Um,
but there are options,
right.
I will happily take questions,
um,
answer anecdote,
quite related queries.
Um,
Yep.
Sorry.
Yeah,
just curious.
Could could have it go differently,
like evolution and everything.
Like what was it she didn't back then?
I think,
I think there were a lot of options.
Um,
I mean it's kind of a deep philosophical question,
sort of can't,
you know,
could anything have gone differently and probably there are other multiple
universes where we're still wandering around doing other things.
But,
um,
I think farming's actually at this sort of idea of the Neolithic of sitting,
settling down and sort of living year round is something that people tried
several times.
So I think we would have always eventually kind of done that.
So there's,
there's actually no evidence that people were sort of messing around with
breeding grains and stuff from I think at like 23,000 years ago,
which is 10,000 earlier than we knew,
but they gave it up.
So it's possible that we actually always would have eventually gotten to this
point.
Um,
but we just,
you know,
we sort of failed a couple of times.
Other than the wisdom teeth you mentioned earlier,
are there any other factors of our lives done now,
which you think the archeologists of the future will be taking up?
And we were having this conversation earlier because I am a text walker and um,
so there's,
there's a combination of things that you just worry about.
You know,
what your neck and your thumb are doing when you're sort of doing this and
whether it,
most of us will end up under buses because we aren't,
you know,
answering some sort of,
uh,
you know,
email or something.
Uh,
it's difficult to know what will affect your skeleton.
I think one of the things that,
um,
we will certainly notice,
it's the number of surgical interventions we will be found with stainless steel,
hip joints and stents,
places and all sorts of interventions.
Uh,
now we've got to the point where actually a lot of the early surgical,
um,
sort of experiments are now archaeological.
There are no longer sort of modern,
but there there's sort of historical enough that we have excavated,
you know,
some of the pioneering surgeons early work and you sort of go,
Ooh,
ah,
glad you practice on dead people.
Um,
so I think we'll probably see increasing signs of human intervention.
Uh,
I think our faces are slowly shrinking.
I'm slightly concerned we are going to end up looking like little gray aliens,
you know,
with the giant skull and the big eyes.
Cause we're super into neoteny,
which is the word for babies are cute.
Um,
yeah,
it's not really high transit anyway.
The same reason that your dog does not look like a wolf.
It looks like a puppy.
And the reason that we find kittens are adorable.
It's,
uh,
supposed to be something that's built in so that because we favor big eyes.
If you look at a baby,
a third of their faces,
which is terrifying unless it's a baby,
in which case it's adorable.
So we actually are supposed to really favor that as a look.
You look at child actors,
many of them have really outsize eyes.
It's something that we find adorable.
Um,
but if we keep on going,
we're gonna run out of jar.
They mostly I and apparently adorable and babies,
but terrifying when it's in a space ship.
So yeah,
not sure what,
what's up with that.
So maybe I just grabbed the long emergency with a little bit too much interest,
but I find the idea of,
um,
civilizations collapsing quite interesting and sort of looking at the examples
that I've seen throughout history,
it seems to happen with much more regularity than modern people.
Imagine.
It does.
And I was wondering through your long view of the historical perspective,
do you think that our current civilization or collection of civilizations is due
to last forever?
Or are we how quite you or any pork or
isn't this is every pub conversation I've had since recent elections.
Um,
I can tell from my accent,
I am American.
Um,
and I'm in a passport here too.
So it's,
it's a conversation that certainly topical and,
and one of the interesting things is,
which keeps me from actively pursuing sort of life under a bus.
Um,
his collapsed doesn't kill everyone.
What we think of collapse.
You can almost kind of see as Emma is this kind of old fashion,
um,
Marxist idea of a revolution where the gears of society and Economics and stuff,
we're sort of mushed in one way and eventually a gear strips.
That's revelation and something happens to change,
but it doesn't kill everyone.
It doesn't destroy everything.
Uh,
we think of,
for instance,
the fall of Rome as a terrible,
terrible thing.
Yeah.
If you were a Roman elite,
turns out for like visit Goss.
It was a great day.
Um,
you know,
they say is not necessarily the end of everything and a lot of things that we
used to think about the dark ages,
you know,
that we'd lost all of the great knowledge of classical world.
No,
it just wasn't easily available.
It was still hanging out somewhere else.
A lot of,
um,
the sort of lost knowledge of classics and things.
They were,
you know,
in North Africa,
in Iran,
places like this.
So when we look at collapse,
you can say there are some really terrifying possibilities,
especially given that someone has a briefcase that can end the world.
I feel like that is not a happy thought,
but we haven't actually managed to massively sink ourselves.
We have certainly managed to upend political orders.
And you do have situations where,
you know,
um,
where,
where I dig in Turkey,
uh,
it is pretty much agrarian,
nowhere land.
It is almost a hundred percent goat population,
but it used to be a major trading point.
You used to be a massively important notice sort of transit.
So things do change and they don't always necessarily change for the better for
those of us who are at the top now.
So it's how you feel you can adapt to that.
And I think,
um,
strategies for adapting to that are really what we want to be thinking about
this.
I'm not necessarily,
how do I live in the coming Dystopia,
you know,
will I need radiation protection?
But,
um,
you know,
uh,
what comes next?
What other organizations follow after this,
this gear slips because it will eventually have slip.
Well,
thank you very much,
Brenda.
That was fascinating that you wrote
[inaudible].